oui j'ai regardé sur mariage j'ai pensé
mais mariage promet quelques 8 n'ont
jamais jamais jamais passé j'ai fait
quoique fou dont 22 au pouvoir commencer
comme
un beau mariage alors le mariage de plus
le plus onéreux voulait way s'est clos
fin décembre a oui c'est vrai ah oui
alors que tf1 n'a pas pu non non non
c'est c'est le magazine un magazine qui
a payé le sport est bien sûr pas rien
perdre en roquettes à 90% qui a payé
alors alors alors ce magazine a fait
faillite depuis en plus c'est vrai
c'était pas hors de france
comme ça voilà d'accord on l'avait vendu
l'exclusivité combien j'ai tout vous
dire comme d'habitude comme ça j'aurai
des tweets l'incendiaire mais de 900000
euros
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que
j'avais j'avais tout tout tout en
décidant maija garder pour moi bien
évidemment et
la barrière c'est fou et où pékin a fait
une seule à l'ump j'aimerais de
bénéfices sur maria cantwell plus cher
que ça la fout pas y aller il y avait
500 personnes ouais le mariage était fou
et avec tout le paf à ce mariage oui
mais quand je vous dit tout y avait il y
avait 80 patron de m6 toutes les stars
ça c'est vedette de télévision et
avaient été témoins dans l'est c'est fou
pardon qui était valérie
invités au mariage et oui voyez j'ai pas
été là bas à la circoncision du petit
mais j'étais mariée
ma mère elle m'a dit el mahdi avait pas
benhaim elma
allemagne avec vista
baby boy avec un évêque qu'une qu'une
anomalie avait que gad elmaleh c'est
tout ouais
t'es dingue ce mariage est oeuvre très
précis un show s'est pas marié et non
mais c est combien il sait que 900 mille
aussi le mariage non parce que mon fils
a des goûts simples quelqu'un quelqu'un
payer le mariage de loti chasse et pêche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non personne n'a payé personne en
février on s'y est tous mis à l es tu
obéniche tu peut le payer
environ 1000 euros par habitant pour a
dit l'europe à 1000 euros par vider sa
compris à 200 personnes ça fait quoi
deux cent mille neuf cent mille barrett
ont arrêté du rectum des mains d'un très
beau mariage là je me suis jamais marié
je comprends pourquoi pas
après on parle de bain jeu mais aussi
beaucoup de gens qui sont pas benjamin
castaldi qui cherche des sponsors et ça
marche très bien comme ça c'est une
nouvelle tendance leur mariage ouais
c'est une nouvelle tendance ou tu tu
cherches toutefois juré express a
plus grand chose ouais voilà résultats
sont les
retours tu autorise par exemple le
traiteur en question à distribuer ses
cartes de visite pendant là c'est
prenant la soirée etc et du cash et
voilà et du coup ça fait moi ça me
choque et un côté entreprise commerciale
qui me choque mariage le prince a les
moyens qu'ils veulent se payer un beau
mariage va pourquoi pas ça peut être
dire allemande ulla sont différentes de
voir les choses alors mariage voilà qui
sont sponsorisés et généralement ils ont
ils ont des sous marins vous aviez des
sous à l'époque pour le faire mais vous
avez eu raison de le faire bah oui quand
je lève alors je les fais pour u2 c'est
que quand on était vraiment traqué par
tout le monde on va faire une séance
photos claires et nettes comme ça y'a
pas de problème on n'était pas du tout
ce qu'il advint s'en souvient pas parce
qu'il était à l'intérieur du mariage lit
mais nous les envoyons m quand on voit
là et que nous nous inviter quand on est
arrivé au fameux château où avait lieu
le mariage de castaldi avec surtout de
grosses et cesserait de broussailles de
brousse et où ça doit cesser dans les
yvelines voilà pour la morena mais y
avait les gendarmes qui balisait la
route il y avait des gens sur les bords
de la bd
oui on va percevoir des coups mais bonne
chance
s'étaient donné le mot en disant qu'il y
avait plein de vedettes qui venait de
benjamin était une immense vedette mais
j'ai toujours dit qu'il y avait des gens
des gens vraiment qu'ils étaient sortant
de la route
non mais vraiment à walibi délégation
qui était faite par la gendarmerie à
visionner aussi bénin non mais tu
délivres les grandes vedettes mais on
avait capté gay mais 90 gardes de
sécurité c'était un truc c'est
incroyable je peux rien dans les arbres
parce qu'ils sont les attributs fois
perché
quoi qu'est ce qu'un nom mais la plus
grande vedette y avait grande vedette
maxime desjardins du tvt ou
non vers il y avait tout à écrire
chanter est ce qu'il ya des gens très
connus en avril expo qui est chouette ah
ouais
[Musique]
calme-toi pas ça qui va changer non mais
ce qui est comique et chanter il ya
moyen moi aussi mes chansons vous vous
avez chanté by coûté en tout cas c'était
pas mal ce n'est pas chanter on va
s'aimer alors ça cesser de tirer sur
lequel je vais rencontrer faible et ça
voilà exactement ouais voilà c'est mais
son étole ou non il y aura la chance on
aurait pu faire plus on va s'aimer mais
pas loin
allez moi
[Rires]
jamais non mais suffisamment pour le g16
magnétiques basse et j'adore d'ailleurs
si moi je serai toujours là pour aider
votre vie